ciao ragazzi e ragazze benvenuti
secondo episodio di youtube in cucina
Oggi vado a cucinare una crostata salata
zucchine broccoli che è ricotta blu
e parmigiano e due uova da non farcire
la massa e quindi la cordada a
supermercati serviamo broccoli
in acqua salata
tagliate le zucchine a fette
[Musica]
e cuocerli in padella con un
poco olio
Mettiamo l'impasto in una fonte per il
forno tagliando l'eccesso
bene prima di amalgamare il tutto
ingredienti per fare il ripieno
dobbiamo prestare il forno a 200
gradi
mettiamo i broccoli e le zucchine
in una ciotola aggiungere 250 grammi di ricotta 2
uova e mescolare bene
[Musica]
per finire aggiungiamo 2 o 3 cucchiai
di formaggio erborinato e una buona quantità di
Parmigiano grattugiato
mescoliamo tutto
di tutti gli ingredienti
ed è quello che avremo
continuiamo a mescolare bene fino ad ottenere
un composto omogeneo che andremo a versare
nella teglia
[Musica]
cuociamo la torta per 20-25
minuti a 200 gradi senza dimenticare
posizionare la torta sul fondo
forno
togliete la torta dal forno e aspettate
lasciarlo raffreddare
[Musica]
ed ecco la nostra torta salata a
buon appetito
[Musica]